[Musique]
nous nous retrouvons donc pour le
premier numéro de subjectif en ce début
d'année 1988 avec quelques reportages
qui je l'espère vont vous plaire vous
distraire vous surprendre ou vous amuser
regardez nous ce bébé tout simplement on
l'adore
[Musique]
merci monsieur
bonjour j'arrive en retard voilà
littoral tout de suite c'est le magazine
Francis le cul qu'elle regarde
portez-vous sur les récents
1 2 3 4 c'est un essai là
qu'est-ce que vous aimez chez un
présentateur de journal qu'il soit
détendu 5 4 3 2
dans le cas du champagne c'est mauvais
dans le cas du champagne on sait que
c'est ça commence
mais non tu penses que je fais aller
les déclarants de récolte les 15000
déclarants de récolte
la récolte de la cuvée 86 c'est pas bon
excuse-moi ça devrait être bon je crois
que j'en ai mis un sacré paquet dans mon
verre j'espère que ces quelques images
vous auront permis de découvrir quelques
traditions de la Vallée d'Aoste avant de
se quitter
juillet dernier le rectorat l'avait
averti qu'à la suite de deux inspections
pédagogiques pédagogique non
satisfaisante nous avons engagé de gros
crédits nous avons des une grosse
affaire sur le dos il faut la faire
prostituer consterné toujours la queue
des kilomètres de queue alors évidemment
cela promet de belles que de belles
queues
ça lui plaisait pas du tout non plus
c'est l'unanimité si gars ce matin comme
d'habitude et puis une pipe à midi on
fait après manger je déguste une pipe et
puis je j'en ai je refais mes une à la
maison ce soir la semaine dernière j'ai
mis 1h30 à faire une pizza c'est de
tirer ses partenaires et de tirer
surtout sa sa jeune campagne mais qui a
été super parce que elle est elle est
elle était jusqu'au bout avec beaucoup
de difficultés mais elle était jusqu'au
bout alors à Poissy combien de fois
avez-vous tiré combien de fois ça fait
déjà plusieurs années que je tire et je
tire toutes les semaines alors je peux
pas je peux pas vous dire combien toute
chaque semaine je continue de tirer moi
je m'entraîne deux fois par semaine et
je vais m'entraîner à côté de chez moi
je fais que tirer que tirer vous voyez
le sommet du guidon
me convient très très bien chaque fois
j'en prends un je les quatre
voilà ça a été dur quand même raison
[Musique]
de cyclo-cross décroche cette fois c'est
sûr Christine
on recommence
entre l'auto et raymo je vais surtout
jouer à griffe
j'espère que vous allez vous remettre
dans une simple normale j'espère que
vous allez vous remettre nous allons
parler athlétisme mais avec le rideau
qui est tombé cet après-midi sur le
championnat de France Narbonne avec un
seul record de France
nous allons voir le résumé de cette
journée avec vous
quand nous gagnons il s'agit du
soviétique Victor Petrenko qui concerne
en fait son titre de champion d'Europe
du championnat d'Europe mais il
semblerait que nous ayons des d'accord
donc nous allons voir donc les images
de dire pas de sport et le voilà ce
sport c'est officiel après vos
je peux pas comprendre
c'est horrible
c'est bon ça tourne
le Parlement
première réaction dans la rue hier après
l'annonce de la fermeture de lunzyn on
recommence de l'île de droite
[Musique]
à
cet instant précis personne personne
ne croyez possible encore qu'un tel acte
se produit
et bien oui et bien oui
qu'on le veuille ou non quelques minutes
plus tard très précisément trois minutes
plus tard
et bien c'était le début de notre
émission arrive après
le perçage du coup plafond ils arrivent
au-dessus de la caisse centralisant les
recettes trois caissières citroues elles
viennent de préparer trois accroches
pour envoyer
les fonds à la banque les cambrioles les
cambrioleurs du faux plafond leur
ordonne de donner les fonds
l'humidité semble vouloir souligner les
douleurs rhumatismales ces douleurs
temps prédestiné peut-être aujourd'hui
au Super Lioran ou l'humidité semble
vouloir
temps prédestiné peut-être aujourd'hui
au Super Lioran où l'humidité semble
vouloir
j'ai pas dit deux fois ça
réuni à ces cinquième journée merde
[Rires]
et ce qui est
aujourd'hui la vie a repris normalement
sur ce foyer de l'ostre aujourd'hui la
vie a repris normalement
bon on reprend depuis le début de la
dernière du dernier paragraphe
vieux con monsieur pourquoi vous êtes là
ce matin et bien voilà nous revendiquons
le remanican
le revendiquant sur
la terre
parce que nous revendiquons
une
revendiquons
ça c'est bête parce que écoutez sur mon
papier c'était bien passez-moi mon
papier donc vous êtes propriétaire ici
d'un appartement la rocade est allongé
sera officiellement inaugurée bientôt
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je préfère
l'agriculture une grande désertification
au niveau de l'agricole
et puis le budget il y a beaucoup de
il ne suffit pas de voter des
il ne s'agit pas d'être notable pour
défendre les Français dans la misère les
Français ça existe il faut il faut en
prendre conscience oui tu sais c'est pas
facile de parler et pour ne rien dire
nous avons un programme établi
vous pourrez pas faire un montage avec
tout ça
comme dans le temps exactement pareil
que dans le temps donc fermeture de
plusieurs magasins de plusieurs points
de vente en boucher artisanat
et ça chauffe pas les autres se
chauffent notre activité à La
Souterraine et très importante par le
nombre de commerces qu'il y a à La
Souterraine la vocation commerciale de
La Souterraine date de déjà de longues
années où nous avions démarché à La
Souterraine souterraine à La Souterraine
La Souterraine l'avenir à La Souterraine
nous avons encore un supermarché qui va
s'insplanter à La Souterraine bien ça va
créer de un gros gros problème ah bien
sûr ça il fait bon vivre La Souterraine
votre voiture est ouverte qu'est-ce que
vous faites avant ce départ
ça commence par regarder mon niveau
d'huile dans le la batterie je me suis
dit pourquoi pas plutôt que d'essayer
d'inventer le fil à couper le plomb
pourquoi pas
mettre du fumier dans la désirateuse à
luzerne
parce que moi personnellement moi j'aime
mieux
les avions
que par exemple le train
il fait du bruit les avions et le train
vous croyez
vous connaissez bretoncel à côté de je
le retrouve il y a des gens qui sont pas
normal je pense qu'il y a des gens qui
sont pas normal un jour nous partons
déménagé un copain
et vlatis pas ce qui s'est passé c'est
colliers on va dormir chez comment
au restaurant hôtel
oui oui mais il y a le Paris le monde
qui pense derrière ça mène l'hôtel en
question et un avion toutes les minutes
ça vous dérange pas ça vous gêne pas non
non
c'est vrai ça comment on dit que vous
avez beaucoup de retraite
est-ce que cette dame a atteint cet âge
respectable grâce à la médecine non non
vous n'avez pas bien posé la question
vous possédez une église du 12e avec
quelques trésors d'art vous voyez elle
est très belle par son unité par les
chapiteaux qui sont très curieux qui
représentent la danse de la bourrée on a
même un franc-maçon qui est statufié
[Rires]
François abasouilly
y a-t-il longtemps que vous êtes dans le
pneu
mais
officiellement je suis installé depuis
1947 donc il y a 37 ans que je suis dans
le pneumatique en tant que délégué des
industries nautiques quelle est la
température du salon cette année la
température est bonne si on peut pas
dire ils ont mis le chauffage hier il
n'y a pas de chauffage la choucroute par
contre
est un peu figé un rôti de porc façon
venaison avec trois garnitures
des produits les plus stratégiques les
plus essentielles au maintien de
l'activité économique il y a combien de
temps que vous êtes ici en Corrèze
je repose ma question
il y a combien de temps que vous êtes
ici à Brive
je dois voir
non mais vous l'avez dit depuis 68 vous
répondez
35 05 oui c'est bien ça je me disais 35
c'est bizarre non c'est 0,5
depuis combien de temps vous êtes ici en
France
plus de 1000 participants qui seront
versés il y a pas plus de
participants qui vont qui ont été versés
c'est 1000 participants qui chacun ont
versé 50 francs pour l'association
regain contre la lutte pour la drogue
contre la lutte je suis complètement
perdu
contrarier
Jean prairial relu avec
66,90% j'en ferai également à la
majorité
voilà pour le pour le pour le
département de la Haute-Loire
excusez-moi expose à la Galerie tangram
à Tours reportage je crois que c'est
excusez-moi je ne sais plus la raté et
12 côtes brisée la suite du procès
demain
j'ai oublié votre nom j'ai envie de dire
que vous peignez un peu avec votre
ventre aujourd'hui vous passez à quoi
aujourd'hui je fais avec mes mains comme
tout le monde
vous faites un film avec autant de
bonheur que vous avez fait votre
écriture pour moi c'est quelque chose de
c'est quelque chose de
c'est la seule chose de pour toute une
série de spectacles sont les spectacles
de danse mais un peu un peu un peu un
peu un peu un peu
les poubelles surtout parce que mon mari
il sait pas les porter
dans cet immeuble et vous en pensez
et vous en pensez quoi de ce problème de
poubelle
mais je suppose que s'ils font la grève
c'est qu'il y a un problème
comme nous pousser un peu le chien
mais il est beau mon chien il est plus
joli que moi c'est pour ça
voilà ça va là comme ça ou pas
des champignons non pardon
c'est
une inventé que nous vous proposons ce
soir nous arrivons à la fin de ce
magazine avec Michel
sont les studios qui ont produit les
dents de la mer Dick Tracy King Kong
c'est le troisième
le japonais
je vais me renseigner auprès de la Régie
et bien nous avons l'illustration tout à
fait immédiate
les images sont théoriquement maintenant
prêtes
les images tout de suite je l'espère
apparemment pas du mal est dans la
lumière du soleil un peu plus que joie
on dirait que c'est à l'intérieur c'est
pas tout à l'heure
prouvant sur place Albert et pas
montialbert mais non non Albert
vous êtes à l'antenne Albert je pense
que vous ne m'entendez pas bon nous
devrions retrouver Albert et qui a été
spontané vous l'avez entendu précisément
et en direct
monsieur Mathieu Proust qui nous relate
cette affaire non non c'est pas possible
non non non tu lui dis que c'est pas
possible
bon et bien écoutez je crois que Mathieu
CROUS ne l'est pas tout à fait prêt
encore
5 6 7 8
et présidents
Richard c'est à vous toute l'équipe se
joint à moi pour vous dire bravo
merci de ce journal La journal un peu
agitée
à tous et très très bonne soirée à tous
au revoir
très très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]